once upon a time Mitt Romney and his
haircut tweeted about president-elect
and popular Sunkist soda flavored Donald
Trump hitting on married women condoning
assault such vile degradation demean our
wives and daughters and corrupt
America's face to the world
but after a whirlwind bromance where the
pair talked about the Secretary of State
job while dining on banner know probably
frog legs and bald eagle wings I don't
know what they eat Romney mister
reporters what a
I'm impressed you couldn't actually see
Trump's lips moving where he stopped his
hand up the tab I lost because it's
official mr. Trump is a better person to
me okay I'm I'm a big baby who goes to
pee in his diaper and Trump is my daddy
what the do people want from me I'm not
a monster me to go out there and grab a
lady in the bathing suit area while
drunk on caffeine I have no dignity left
alright so clearly clearly Trump made
Romney say all that so if he wants to
become Secretary of State yet say that
comedians what are some other things
mitt will have to admit to join Trump's
cabinet jamayne he will have to reveal
the Mormon who Styles his wigs and
merkins yes
my Colina buck
he'll have to say my carefully
cultivated image as an elder statesman
of the GOP was actually a tinsel thin
veneer I was willing to shove up my own
asshole in order to get a job with a man
I swore to oppose